foreign
[Music]
all I know is I'm playing like a 20
something 100 GM
200 2700
okay here we go this is a fun line
this is a very fun line
so G3 is like the best try I think
maybe I guess there's Bishop g42
yeah this is uh this is one of the main
reasons I
still play Stafford
because even Grand Masters I'll show the
name
even GMS are capable of falling into
this
and then
um
the outside line Queen H5
a threatening made into
haven't had this one in a while
like the double P sack
Bishop F3 I can take
wait a minute
yeah let's just
just crushing
okay
14 move win
against the GM that was nice
uh
yeah this is why white has to play G3
um instead of H3
but H3 it's very logical because it
seems like Knight G4
was already a threat
and it's actually interesting too like
the engine if you turn on engine here
it'll take a moment for it to understand
the position
Queen D4
yeah I'll say like Plus for white and
then all of a sudden
you give it more time and I realizes
Knight G4 is winning
um because of the I mean it's all
because of Bishop F2
not for Bishop F2 white would be fine
and then the fun line is takes here here
here here
and I'm preparing queen's eye castling
that game might go on YouTube as a
standalone video